so what what it is is that
a lot of the time
women hear things
that men don't say this is what i've
because i've been sitting here listening
to the conversation
a lot of women hear things that men
don't say he's not insinuating that
that's okay
he never said that it's okay absolutely
not but the fact that
you jumped to that so that is
a crazy thank you that is far right on
that is on the scale to say that that's
he's not saying that and the thing is my
thing is why
how did you get to that conglomerate how
did you get to him saying exactly i'll
apologize because i'm not
sure i'm
of course
but by you implying that a woman what a
woman wears and how she walks
that it's okay then for a man to
approach her that implies that it is
okay then for a man to do what she wants
because he likes to do what she looks
like if he wants to talk to her if he
wants to try get her number if he wants
to make her feel intimidated because
he's trying to get her number like when
i come up to you in the middle of the
night and i say hi miss is that what you
you coming up to me later if i'm waiting
for a cat i've had it happen before
like you are six foot something you are
so much bigger than me you coming up to
me at this time of night i'm just trying
to get home i'm not trying to interact
with anyone i just want to get home when
do you ever want to interact
you'll know if i want if i if i come up
to you you'll know if i want to interact
with you so the only time you want to
interact is when you come up to me
if i want to interact with you
remember
earlier on so this so this is the great
area that we men get confusing i think
so it's like if women get no attention
they're not happy right
but if they get attention at the wrong
time they're not happy
but if they get attention at the right
time they're happy and men a lot of men
generally do not know when that right
time is to give you the attention they
men generally don't know so energy
so but that's the thing if a man as a
man being a um
a hunter let's say right he sees his
quote-unquote prayer i know these people
don't like these analogies but i'm just
using it as an analogy right and he says
oh that looks nice i'm gonna go and see
what that's saying right
at what time is it okay for him to do
that
because because what you're saying is
it's not okay after two o'clock in the
morning
no but it's just after two years no but
i'm saying generally it's more
vulnerable
because it meant because what i'm trying
to say is men genuinely yeah go for it
men generally don't know
you're gonna tell them
[Laughter]
like men generally don't know
um
when that time is so like you know when
a woman's feeling you right if like
she'll make i if she makes eye contact
you said about the brushing past all
those little things that's showing a
sign that she yes it is that she's
interested and you know it is because
she said earlier i mean this in the
sense of this yeah what time is it are
you saying men should be able to read
time
well hold on this this will satisfy him
if it's dark outside you see it's dark
outside and say if if the girl is with a
group of friends then it might be
acceptable but if it's dark outside and
no one is around there's no need to walk
up to someone like sure you they might
be attractive but there's no need like
there will be other women that's not the
only woman in the world that you've ever
found attractive there will probably be
someone else like you said women are
easy to find
beautiful women
for the top 10 percent of men
and for the other for the other
20 the other 80 do not get beautiful
girls half of them are virgins and the
other half haven't had um sex in a year
let me ask you a question do you see why
what do you see why the women are a
little bit
side eye at what you're saying do you
know i know why they are it's because
they're looking at as the guy that's not
their type no i'm not no i'm not it
doesn't matter if you know if you see
that someone is by themselves
like that and that's he just asked what
would be acceptable and we're saying oh
this would be acceptable and you're
still saying no no you feel that way the
reason why i say that is because you're
not every girl so some girls might be
like later it's two o'clock i just come
from a club yet of course that's the
time to church me no but like the
difference i said if they're with
friends okay so if you're when like
you're coming from the club i would
think you would be with friends no
speaking from experience let's finish
most people most girls even girls we
stay together we stay together and you
guys know that oh why are you always
going to the bathroom together we stay
together we're always together so in
that sense yeah that's fine to walk up
to someone because they're in a crowd
but
um
if if it's a one person and then even if
it's one person you're saying they're
coming out of the club they're probably
drunk so why are you wanting to like
approach someone that is intoxicated and
vulnerable exactly
when you're drunk you're vulnerable yeah
because you're intoxicated so when you
drive when you're drunk you're
vulnerable you shouldn't drive back
exactly so that means that the law sees
it as you're completely able to decide
whether or not as an adult whether you
if you drink and drive you're completely
responsible for yourself
what what if you drink and drive it's
not the man's food that you drunk and
drive so when you when you drink and
walk you should be able to be
responsible as well how can you drink
alcohol and walk down the road that you
so think is the most dangerous place